so it's 9:30 everyone good morning and
we'll start today's cabinet meeting
right first item apologies for absence
received and declarations of interest by
councillors any day yep thank you
item 11 community infrastructure levy I
think I ought to declare at least I eat
local non-pecuniary interest insofar as
there is an application from Newton
which is shown on the schedule the land
at which the playing equipment that's
being bid for will be placed his own
bonnet and green trust and I am a
trustee of Newton green trust so I think
at the very least a local non-pecuniary
I don't know if there needs to be any
any more than that nope okay that's fine
Thank You counselor right the next item
is BCA 1940 to confirm the minutes of a
meeting held on the 11th of February
which shows the last month's meeting so
you've got the the meeting minutes in
front of you I'll go on the page numbers
as that is shown here we've got page 5
page 6 page 7 page 8 page 9 page 10 page
11 and finally page 12 does anyone have
any comments on those minutes okay then
everyone happy to approve the minutes or
improve thank you
all right the next item and to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme and
questions by councillors the matters
referred by the overview scrutiny or
joint audit and standards committees
thank you
moving on to item seven forthcoming
decisions list
you've all got the link to that have you
had a chance to look through other any
comments on items coming up to cabinet
and Council over the next few months
everyone happy with that yep
Castle Busby an obvious decision is how
long are we going to continue meeting in
person and she's not on it I'll give you
a covert answer and then I look to the
montrose to give a legal answer so in
terms of Kovac you would expect that we
are regularly meeting in relation to
that eagerly awaiting the outcome of the
cobra meeting today and yes that will be
or something we would need to consider
thank you chair just from my perspective
obviously we would look to keep our
regulatory functions going for as long
as possible but if there was any advice
around not holding public meetings or
not being able to access this building
for example to hold meetings we would
either have to find alternative
locations or cease meeting but of course
in that situation if there were any
urgent decisions that needed to be taken
the chief executive does have emergency
powers to take urgent decisions which
are then reported back to the full
council or to the
I'm decision-making body thereafter
Kessler Davis
yeah so it's only but and would we be
illegally would we legally be allowed to
Skype from home collectively with the
facility that the public could see you
know what was going on and obviously I
don't know if there's a way of being
able to to react to what was being said
they wouldn't be able to speak anyway
because the public don't and I would we
legally be allowed to do that would do
the public have to be in the room so
that the first part of that around could
all the members of the relevant
committee or a cabinet for example
participate remotely the answer is no so
there is no provision because of when
the legislation was implemented they
obviously didn't think about virtual
meetings at that stage so for the
purposes of actually convening a meeting
all the members have to be there in
person the meeting has to be held in
public but that doesn't necessarily mean
that members of the public have to be in
attendance
so actually screening meeting
live-streaming in the way that we do now
satisfies that requirement of openness
so you would still be able to me even if
we can allow members of the public into
the building but you would actually have
to be here in person for the meeting to
go ahead anything else on what on that
company if we're going to look at
reducing the number of meetings I think
the meeting that we're going through
today it's very similar to the briefing
session that we ever got a week ago we
could almost ditch the briefing and go
straight to the meeting and have any
debate in that it won't be quite so
seamless but at least it saves one one
meeting for everybody yeah so I think
that's something you want to think about
outside the meeting but certainly what I
would say in taking the lead from what
the luncheon officer just said your
briefings can be done virtually so
that's no problem at all and because
those are the briefing discussions
between yourselves and then you would
only be coming
get there for meeting such as this okay
so having got all that clarified are we
happy with the forthcoming decisions
list as it sounds thank you great moving
on then the next item is paper BCA 1941
the general fund financial monitoring
for 2019 to 2020 caught three monitoring
so I'm pleased to represent report BCA
1941 to cabinet which is the general
fund quarter three financial monitoring
for the current year the report covers
the general fund revenue budget and the
general fund capital program and
presents the latest assessment of how
these compare with the budget for this
year please note that the cost to
monitoring papers were circulated but
not debated by cabinet due to the
council meeting in December we now have
nine months data on which to base our
extract relation for the full year and
so we have much more certainty about the
trends that the report shows although we
have a long track record of historically
delivering financial outcomes ahead of
budget these have been primarily driven
by increased income so we must never be
complacent we must always keep a tight
watch and continually monitor our
expenditure against budget as before we
have adopted the tolerance level of 10%
when identifying key variances of the
full year forecast compared to budget
these are set out in Appendix A and with
detailed narrative explanations provided
in paragraph 5.7 we are now anticipating
a surplus of six hundred and thirteen
thousand pounds compared to budget that
figure of course is net of favorable and
adverse variances in the many cost
centers and income streams so I will
highlight the major variances there's a
55,000 pounds adverse variance for costs
associated with the former headquarters
site of course Lane due to delays in
commencing work and this is now expected
to start late spring or early summer
there is a 58 thousand pound adverse
variance for open spaces do to reduce
Suffolk County Council contribution for
grass cutting and repairs at Bellevue
Park there's a 29,000 pounds adverse
variance for expenditure on car parks
and mainly due to business rates
incurred
on the positive side we are showing a
463 thousand pound favorable variance
for planning primarily due to additional
planning income with some with some for
professional charges and appeal costs
and we're also expecting a surplus
licensing income of forty three thousand
pounds and a surplus in Silla
administration fee income of twenty two
thousand pounds and finally we have some
adjustments to our business rates
collection which we will fund through
the established business rates
equalization reserve this has worsened
considerably since quarter one primarily
due to a significantly worse position
for baseline business rates the section
31 graphs and business rates pool have
improved however and we know this is
always difficult to budget for which is
why the reserve was established and last
year we transferred one point eight four
six million pounds to that reserve as
stated in paragraph five point eight we
are likely to be able to make a
significant contribution to reserves at
year-end but it should be noted that the
additional planning for you income is
unlikely to be repeated next year the
position will be kept under review and
final recommendations presented to
out-earn
paragraph five point thirteen of the
report summarizes the currently
predicted movements in the
transformation fund with a forecast
balance of 255 thousand pounds at the
end of the year at this stage we're not
showing any transfer of surplus to this
as it is likely along with other
reserved movements to change our era
marked reserves were nine point six
million pounds at April 2019 and are
expected to reduce eight point nine
million pounds at the end of this month
the transfers to and from these reserves
are summarized in paragraph five point
15 with a detail in appendix D our
general fund capital programs detailed
at dependency that is currently
forecasting a capital expenditure of six
point four seven million pounds which
means an understand of fifteen point six
five million pounds both of these
numbers are excluding Cisco the main
points to note are provided in paragraph
five point nineteen and are the fact
that we are expecting to reduce capital
spend on mandatory disabled facilities
grants by seven one hundred and seventy
six thousand pounds due to our adapt a
reduced spend of the annual budget the
recently approved increase in a drop
grant threshold to seven thousand five
pose will help to improve this situation
we will carry forward 400,000 pounds for
grants for affordable housing and we
anticipate carrying forward 440 thousand
pounds for the ongoing work at
Kingfisher and Hadley leisure centers
and we are also anticipating carry
forwards totaling fifteen point five
hundred million pounds and these include
Cisco for investment and commercial
delivery the details of this are given
in paragraph 519 D all the detail on
revenue variances can be found in
Appendix A Appendix B details our
transformation fund Appendix C shows how
we're spending the business rates pilot
appendix D sets out the general fund EMR
preserves including forecast transfers
and appendix E contains all the detail
on capital variances now finally in my
report to Council on next year's
treasury management strategy I did say
that
following the Bank of England decision
to hold interest rates at zero point
seven five five percent in November
I'll enclose our treasury advisers were
forecasting that they would remain at
this level for the foreseeable future
well here we are a couple of weeks later
and it goes to show that forecast in the
future is fought with difficulty even
for the experts
so before opening up for questions and
debate on the report I'd first like to
move the recommendations in section 3 of
the report on page 13 recommend
move that they be noted and may I have a
seconder for these recommendations
please Castle ml BC thank you members of
the cabinet are there any questions on
the quarter 3 monitoring councillor
Busby you talked about planning given a
favorable variance that we've got at the
moment you said this was a likely to be
repeated next year to you what do you
anticipate that planning volume
delighted to be less or no I think in a
probably miss will cooperate this that
the the fee level for next year has been
estimated based on on the current work
and predicted workload it's just in this
current year there was considerably
extra that they came in that wasn't
anticipated at the time the budget was
set last year
who says that
so what increase the budget anyone else
cousin Aarthi just got a question on
face right and the implications for us
because of course at different times and
for different reasons we're both
borrowing and lending money some of the
money that we borrow is his sort of
fixed term borrowing and I just wondered
what the implication was for us if there
was a sort of an easy explanation what
the implication is for us for the
reduction in base rate and yes so a lot
of the borrowing that we do for bebo is
short term borrowing from other local
authorities so we expect that to drop
with the interest rate as well currently
we were borrowing about 0.7% so we
expect that to reduce there will be a
benefit to our short term borrowing but
I'm writing assuming that the Public
Works loanable borrowing is is not going
to be because because we borrow it that
time the interest rates are set at the
time we borrow from BW lbs so the
existing boring won't be impacted come
on so if the baby we haven't actually
locked into any Peter we will be
borrowing for safe care or anything at
the moment but obviously we're keeping a
close eye on that because that does
track the markets as well on the rates
as well so if that does take a dip we've
all take a look at but we can't borrow
in advance of our needs so if we don't
need to borrow we we're not allowed to
so its own
before I go to Council McRoy if there
any other questions for members of the
cabinet cousin Busby obviously the
chrono virus is gonna have an impact on
the way they operate I don't think it's
gonna impact perhaps this year we've got
one more quarter to report on but
obviously for next it's obvious too
early to try and work out what kind of
impact is gonna have on the numbers are
we anticipating doing a coronavirus
budget or revised budget we've already
set and approved the budget for 2022
2021 I think the best we can do is to
track it in the the monitoring in each
quarter that's a fair comment isn't it
that's that's fine monitoring after the
event I'm thinking is there anything we
can do to overcome any potential
increasing costs that we all like to
have what can we predict in advance to
minimize the effect of this it's all
well we don't want to just get to the
ending in signal with 500,000 pounds
overspent because of this and we
couldn't do anything about it
couldn't we AC it's gonna be very
difficult to predict how how would
impact our our budget at all I mean we
know what the government has done in
terms of business rates relief and in
terms of statutory sick pay which is
going to help individuals in terms of
that their their council tax payments
but I'm not sure that this there's
nothing else that sorry yes and I think
so just to come in on that what we are
looking at planning for is a lot of
staff so what that might do to the
budget is have an impact on the loss of
income so if we've got building control
food safety officers licensing off
there's that kind of thing that having
income generation within their team it
could have an impact on that so what
we'll do is part of our business
continuity is when we're planning for
lots of staff we can start
think what that might do to income and
it won't necessarily give us a journey
to get that income back within the year
and because you know surveys aren't
going out to to survey houses and sign
of building works the builders aren't
gonna be out there doing the work either
so that there will be a drop and across
the whole sector for that kind of thing
and but we will be as chair has already
said be putting into our budget paper to
show what that was so we might be able
to map it to expect to have an
expectation of what that impact would be
though isn't necessarily a route to
generate that income back again I guess
face guys castle Davis yeah I was gonna
bring this up in any other business but
I think this is a natural time to
include this and SRP last night I asked
about obviously business rates are being
held by the government but in terms of
council tax being paid and of course you
know not just our stuff but a lot of
stuff could find themselves in a very
difficult situation now we do have
provision within the rules that we have
already about people hardship funds and
people being able to take a break if
they notifies but do you think it's
worthwhile that this cabinet asks how we
can move forward so if something if it
got really bad later on I'm talking
about particularly council tax but it
could extend out here a paper on the
effect the possible effect and what the
candidates who reacts in a certain
situation because I think we need to be
ready if in two three months time when
if if coronavirus really bites in terms
of people especially the self-employed
who are not able to pay their council
tax and rather than ending up with a
criminal record because we do we tend to
call very quickly that you know there is
some sort of leeway
I think that would help us reputation me
as well yeah Thank You counselor
certainly what we are looking generally
in terms of assisting people in
difficulties with council tax which is
why we've approved the Citizens Advice
protocol last month so that definite
self should should help in terms of
working with individuals that they do
find themselves in difficulty but I take
the point that there's probably some
other things we can do can you come back
on them yes so just last night actually
there was some information and posted on
self employment and around coronavirus
and what people can do so the employment
and Support Allowance ESA can be claimed
from day one everyone is rather than day
eight for those who are self employed
and don't have and statutory syncope so
that that is obviously quite new news
and there's no massive detail around
that but I would expect more detail to
come out about that so I absolutely I
think we should be signposting those who
are self-employed or don't have access
to sick pay and to the ESA and
government benefit casseroles well
thanks guys thank you miss Jenny and
yeah as someday as councillor Davis has
just alluded to we did discussed it at
the shared revenue partnership meeting
yesterday and I think what we agreed on
was that some guidance be put to the
offices within that partnership so that
if if and when it does hit hard
they've got guidance so that they've got
clear lines on where they what they do
and and how they go about it rather than
feeling in the dark and also there's the
issue that if at any time a lot of the
offices are off from the shared revenue
partnership and we have to put other
staff in there to manage the situation
then they've got clear guidelines on
what they can do when it does start to
hit hard and I think that's the approach
that we were coming from the shared
revenue partnership point of view so
that we're prepared for it basically
okay understand that and we will have to
see what we can do in that respect okay
castle McCraw do you have a question a
question a bit of an observation it was
just about I thought that when interest
rates are a half a percent of a quarter
of a cent all three quarters of the
percentage it seems that the difference
between those is actually relatively low
I mean they're low interest rates
whatever you call them and anything
below 1% is low and so there's going to
be changes of the margin will gain some
swings and roundabouts effects either
way however the effect of the interest
rates in terms of the council's
financials is I think probably the least
of the financial effects that the
council might face through coated 19 so
worrying about interest rates is a
little bit like sort of done worrying
about the straw when you know you've got
a dirty great brick wall coming up to
you or he's just you know it's a
different scale so I don't think we
should get a live set about interest
rates hey thank you thanks does anyone
else have any questions or comment
comments on the quarter 3 position my
point of view I think that the surplus
is is good it's to be welcomed and
obviously it's an improvement on on the
original budget significant improvement
which is going to help us but apart from
that the position is looking quite quite
good I would say
anyone got any further comments if not
we'll take it to the vote say is that
it's a remarkable thing if you can get
the department that a brings in the huge
positive variance and wins award for its
IT it humbles the two doesn't normally
go hand in hand yet some of the the
planning department is is doing very
well at the moment and
making money and being innovative and
we're seeing housing applications
approved and housing being delivered so
all in all a very good success story
thank you
right oh so we've got the
recommendations in paragraph three
proposed and seconded all those in favor
thank you right moving on then the next
is paper BCA 1942 the housing revenue
account the national monitoring for 2019
2020 quarter three so I'm pleased now to
introduce report BCA 1942 to cabinet
which is the housing revenue account
called three financial monitoring for
this year the report covers the HRA
revenue budget and the HRA capital
program and this report likely general
fund report extrapolates a forecasted
outcome for the full year based on
actual data for the first nine months of
international year the original budget
for 2019 to 2020 showed a deficit of 193
thousand pounds which would be balanced
by withdrawing monies from reserves
however we will need to use more
reserves as we are now forecasting a
deficit in 513 thousand pounds which is
an adverse variance of 320 thousand
pounds against the budget and the
worsening since quarter to a summary of
the variances had provided in paragraph
5.6 of the report and full details can
be found in paragraph 5.7 the deficit
should however be seen in the context of
our healthy reserves which will still be
in excess of 12 million pounds even
allowing for that deficit and as
described in paragraph 5.7 as all always
with the HRA the short-term outlook
should always be reviewed within the
context of our 30-year HRE business plan
and I should say that also that the
picture improves going forward once the
government posed rent reduction ceased
in April 2020 and the effects of this
are seen in the 2020 to 2021 budget that
was approved last month which shows a
significant surplus of three hundred and
thirty-four thousand pounds paragraph
5.6 in the report on page 31 clearly
shows that the biggest drivers of the
variants are shortfall in rental income
and an increase in the forecast
repairs and maintenance we've got
dwelling rental income 115,000 pounds
below budget due to timing of new build
new build homes being completed non
dwelling income which is primarily
garage rental is 52 thousand pounds
below budget due to voids property
services are showing an adverse variance
of one hundred and one thousand pounds
due to an increase in repairs and
upgrades to equipment in the whole house
servicing contract although this has
improved since quarter two and also more
to be spent on asbestos surveys the
personal maintenance is showing an
adverse variance of four hundred and
seventy seven thousand pounds resulting
from an overspend onic external
contractors due to the increase in
responsive repairs to reduce the backlog
about outstanding jobs however this is
an improving trend reducing from 668
thousand powers in 2018-19 and eight
hundred and forty thousand powers in
2017 to 2018 so that's just under two
hundred thousand pounds a year
improvement over the past few years set
again sees as the under spend due to the
slippage in the capital program which
I'll move on to next the HRA capital
program is set out in paragraphs five
point eight to 5.10 and also Appendix A
planned maintenance capital spend is
anticipated to remain at budget levels
for the year as projects are completed
later in the year relating to fire
prevention and the electrical standards
likewise our new build capital spend
will be primarily in the last nine
months of the year as development
progress progress and new projects
identified gain we're not anticipating
any underspend our capital expenditure
to date is seven hundred seven point
seven six million pounds against the
budget of twenty nine point four three
six million pounds the full-year spend
is estimated being eleven point nine
million pounds resulting in
carryforwards of seventeen point five
million pounds primarily due to the new
builds and acquisitions program the
delays of the start of Angel Court and
courts lane are the primary causes of
this so before opening up for questions
on the report I'd first like to remove
the recommendations in section 3 of the
report on page
31 that the shortfall of 320,000 powers
be noted and at the capital program be
noted and may I have a seconder for
these recommendations please counsel
Osborn thank you
does anyone have any questions on the HR
a quarter three position
it is I can think of one don't you worry
property serves it planned maintenance
with 10% over budget on planned
maintenance I understand being over
budgets on response responsive repairs
maintenance but some of the way we've
planned it in advance he seems we should
be spot on as a second part of that when
do we review or how often do we review
what is planned and I've got a being a
bonnet about replacing rules every 25
years which has got to be expensive and
I live in a village that's about 40
years old and I think there's been one
roof replaced in out of 500 so while we
do them every 25 years
how often do we review that at that time
frame okay Thank You councillor Busby
feel question in relation to plan
maintenance program I think it's fair to
say that we've been in a transitional
period because we haven't had the stop
condition data it's made it more
difficult to plan long-term improvements
to our homes but as you'll be aware we
have employed to stall condition
surveyors that have been actively
visiting our properties and carrying out
an assessment as to their condition to
ensure that going forward we do have a
funded plan Tamilians program that is
scheduled in that way that you described
and I think we are seeing the fruits of
that now some of the additional adverse
variants are as a result of carrying out
additional works
asbestos surveys being such an area as
well as other Health and Safety type
work such as fire risk assessment and
the alike we have recently just been
through a restructure of the team and as
a result we have employed an additional
asbestos surveyor and fire risk Assessor
baya that we expect to then reduce our
dependency
external contractors to provide that
that work so I foresee that will be
making savings we've also been in
negotiations with for some of our
contractors particularly around the
whole house servicing contract and as a
result of those conversations we are
changing the specification in for
example the type of boiler that we
install and the type of consumer unit
that we install based on ensuring that
we're compliant with with regulations
but possibly not putting in the example
art uses consumer units with been put in
arc detection consuming units it's a
recommendation but it's not a
requirement and as a result we've made
the decision in the past month to revert
to an alternative that will save one
hundred thirty six thousand pounds next
year based on this year's current spend
so we are doing lots of that work to
look at the components look at the type
of components that we that we provide we
are looking at the life cycles of our
components we have traditionally over
recent years push those out and extended
them to make savings but we are
currently carrying out our review as
well thank you Karen just a quick
question not on the boilers so are we
ensuring that the boilers that we
install now would be capable of burning
hydrogen should the guest supply be
changed that isn't something that we are
doing at the moment we are actively in
talks with our contractor and we are
looking at new technologies to look at
beyond obviously the phasing out of gas
we are in still installing gas boilers
as we speak today but we are actively
looking at alternative solutions so that
we minimize that the long-term effects
of of gas boilers the example that I use
for gas boilers are we've talked to the
suppliers we've talked to the contractor
we can install a boiler that is as
efficient as the boiler that we're
installing currently but save a hundred
pounds on every boiler when you're
installing 500 boilers a year that's a
significant saving
Thank You Kathy that's just a little bit
more on the answer to councillor Busby's
question really because looking at the
papers on page 33 you can see I mean all
those mention about specialist and all
that sort of stuff the the biggest chunk
is repairs and maintenance and we're
told the majority of that can be
attributed to expenditure in relation to
the use of subcontractors so I'm
presuming although Gavin didn't sort of
major on the use of subcontractors I
presume that this is responsible for the
majority of the the overall variance
isn't it yes councillor fee you are
correct and that's primarily because
we've had a long-standing backlog of
repairs since the inception of building
services I can report that in recent
weeks we've reduced that
work-in-progress from nearly 7,000 job
tickets to 4,000 in in just over eight
weeks I think that's really positive in
terms of that means that customers are
getting their jobs done and getting them
done more efficiently and quickly we are
looking at the use of subcontractors and
we are attempting to reduce our reliance
on subcontractors just to give you some
examples of the interventions that we
are currently working on we're currently
recruiting in that service to two
carpenters one laborer and two
apprentices they will be some
replacements but also utilizing
vacancies that we've had within the team
we're looking at our contractors the
example I would give is is fencing where
we use a contract to deliver lots of
responsive repairs to defences we're
looking at capitalizing some of that
through new contracts that will be
tended for we're reducing our demand in
relation to void contractors and doing
more of that in-house we're also
identifying those areas where we've
traditionally used specialist
contractors the example that uses uPVC
repairs to windows and doors we're in
fact
we're now looking at training internal
staff existing staff to carry out those
repairs which again will reduce our cost
on on reliance of contractors and we've
also just recently restructured the team
within building services in recent
months as well Thank You Gavin any other
questions councillor Osbourne
on redoing that that particular flat or
house is that more do you spend more
money now than you have in the past is
it is it another tranche of of further
investment so I wouldn't just just talk
about those tenants that sadly password'
talk possibly about the quality of
properties being returned to us as and
when they become void for a variety of
reasons and it has been the case that
over the last probably 18 months 2 years
we have identified and recognized that
actually when properties returned to us
we are having to invest more money in
bringing them up to an illegible or an
acceptable standard before we can really
let rillette those properties having
identified that and identified it's a
cost to repairs and maintenance we have
for recent restructures now have an
officer in post who is visiting every
person who's in and but in bands a B and
C on our Housing Register so we can
assume that those people are likely to
be the people that move in the near
future that Officer is going out
surveying the property talking to the
tenant about the level of repairs that
need to be undertaking to bring that
standard up to an acceptable standard
and where we identify actually the level
of repairs or the condition of the
property means that we will sanction
that tenant in a way in terms of reduced
their preference will reduce their their
place in their housing register until
they've brought the property up to
standard so I'd expect to say that Sam I
mean that is a long-term ambition we've
got one off so obviously visiting many
many people on the Housing Register but
over over the short and medium term I
would expect to see that reduce the
course as an when properties become void
benefit is obviously less time to take
as well thank you Miss Joe thanks Kevin
okay then if it nobody has anything else
they want to ask or discuss then we've
had the recommendations section three
proposed and seconded may take a vote
please
all those in favor thank you Thanks
okay moving on the next item is paper
BCA 1943 the quarter three performance
outcome reporting and our last slot
Parker to introduce this please Thank
You Chet
yep I'm pleased to present cabinet with
third quarter performance outcome report
the cabinet recommendation is to agree
that the report and appendices
adequately reflect the council's
performance of a quarter three work is
underway to review performance measures
for communities to align with the
community strategy other than that chair
I'd just like to thank the assistant
directors and indeed the members for
their continued support in reviewing the
performance to ensure that the
information captured therein is relevant
to the council's priorities and
corporate outputs are we happy to take
any questions Thank You councillor yeah
we've got a good set of reports here now
and wait to see when the community sir
starts reporting in the similar fashion
but it's they're looking good does
anyone have any questions or any points
I wish to make on any of these council
about castle Davis yeah first of all I'd
like to reiterate what council Parker
said it yeah they really are improving
the time and time again and I know
councillor Busby has his own opinion
about how things are presented but I
think they're done in a very good way I
think this is there's a couple couple of
points from the performance indicators
that I'd like to to highlight and
compliment really maybe ask the question
why in particular sickness is down
considerable 600 days you're or less so
I think that's a really provement on
know a lot of workers go near by the
various managers and because I know if
they weren't
all been work-related sickness but I
think there was a problem in the past
and I'm glad to see that he's slowly but
surely being addressed so I think that's
worth highlighting and also in terms of
customer service my own personal
experience and shortly continues to be
positive I have to say so I think the
team that go up there the officers that
go up there they're incredibly
enthusiastic you know they're right out
and they're really helpful and I think
the numbers are creeping up in terms of
people get in there and go in there and
I know we want more people to go online
all the time but that the service that
they offer those people that can't or
don't quite understand the internet as
well as some of us do it's vital for
them and then they are taught how to
access our system and go on so I think
those two particular things and it's
great to see the core times and
everything else coming down so
congratulations to councillor Parker and
Sarah and her team Thank You councillor
any other comments from anyone Khosla
Busby I think the style is fantastic
without taking too much away from what
you all the plaudits that you're getting
mr. Parker I know this has been a
decrease in the number of people
streaming these meetings from 3,000 down
to 1200 have you got a strategy for
bringing the numbers back up
just really to make sure that you're in
front of the camera laughter no I there
are that there's some comments within
the report that gives some indication as
to why you view viewings are going up
and down I suspect that they probably
will increase over over the period of
time and particularly you know coming
back to what we were talking about you
know the more meetings we stream the
more the more viewings there will be
that is the direction of travel notes
that's the way that things will be in
the future I'm quite sure but difficult
to explain little individual spikes yeah
I think we'll hopefully cuthie was a dip
because of the general election and
we'll see it pick up a cue
and further increases next year as well
but we just need we need to see a
longer-term trend before we can know
whether it's going in the right
direction or the wrong direction and
whether q3 is as it's suspected and
anomaly in q3 we did have the
pre-election moratorium for the general
election so actually there were fewer
meetings that were available to watch so
that would account for the reduced
number of viewings does anybody have
anything else they want to discuss about
any of the other performance measures no
okay
that's the party you've proposed this
may have a seconder please councillor
Davis all those in favor
thank you okay the next item paper BCA
1944 community infrastructure levy
expected sil expenditure business ban
March 2020 and where I asked castle
Aarthi to introduce this please
Thank You chairman yes you've got the
report for the latest bid round these
come to you every six months with
recommendations for your approval and
noting of the delegated decisions the
report has a business plan which is
Appendix A at pages 109 to 1 to 9 and
the technical assessments for the
individual SIL bids which you always
have as well which is Appendix B that's
pages 131 to 143 also we give you an
update on progress on the previous bid
rounds and that's at pages 1 to 7 to 1
to 9 in your recommendations there are
four bids three for your approval
decision today and one for you to note
as a delegated decision which has
already been taken
so decisions for you today from the
local infrastructure front fund for East
built
that's proposal Civil Works to the
comfortable Memorial Hall
involving a new kitchen and access to
the lounge it's collaborative sill bid
for fourteen thousand three hundred and
thirty three pounds with a community
grant of sixteen thousand six hundred
and sixty-six and the total cost of the
works being fifty thousand parents
that's recommended for fund allocation
from the local infrastructure fund taken
fourteen three three three
I'm pleased to report there's another
bid from Kok field they've been involved
in most of their hands how this one is a
bid for a new adventure playground a
collaborative beard with the council
being asked for 25,000 pounds out of a
project that costs at sixty eight
thousand six hundred and forty seven
pounds including VIP and the parish
council are funding the remainder
through their own neighborhood sill and
some preset and reserves and donations
so the recommendation for you this
morning is that we approve twenty five
thousand pounds towards that project
then we have bids from ring-fenced funds
and the first of those is in Lavenham
again i'm pleased to report that one of
the bid is for a new car park which is
on land of water street the land is
being transferred to the parish from the
current owner which is National National
Grid gas I think they called for one
pound there are other issues that will
be addressed with regard to the gas
holder on the site as well which is a
scheduled ancient monument that's not
part of this bid this bid is for the for
the car park again it's a collaborative
bid the council is being asked for
190,000 pounds out of a project that
costs approximately two hundred and
thirty-eight thousand pounds and the
remaining monies are being provided
by the parish council some of that is
out of their neighborhood sill and some
out of their preset so the
recommendation is for cabinet to approve
that bid for a hundred and ninety
thousand pounds and then lastly we've
got cocoa Saint Mary which is a bid for
a new bus shelter in thorny Road
originally submitted by Co person Mary
but Suffolk County Council is now joined
in the beard so it's a joint bid it's a
100% bid
being undertaken under the sill position
statement for passenger transport
improvements the decision to approve
this bid was taken under delegated
powers on the 13th of faith so that's
just for your noting finally just to
summarize the amount of spent we've got
a total expenditure in be around for
from the local infrastructure fund of
thirty nine three three three those are
the ones in Cocke field and east berg
alt and total expenditure for
ring-fenced funds of a hundred and
ninety eight thousand pounds that's the
hundred and ninety thousand pounds for
Lavenham and the eight thousand pounds
for cocoa sent Mary
so the recommendations are set out in
the report at paragraph three point one
that's for its burgled cot field and
Lavenham and to note the decision made
at cab Capel and paragraph three point
two you're asked to note and endorse the
SIL business plan I will just add um I
know sometimes people ask questions
about this sort of thing [ __ ] field of
course have benefited from several
successful bids starting with the very
first big round I will just point out to
you that so far development in cot field
has resulted in two hundred and fifty
seven thousand pound
being collected in in silk that's
already being collected by us into the
one two three fund and Lavenham I will
just mention already collected is some
eighty thousand pounds but there is
three hundred and fifty seven thousand
pounds do you into our still wanted
refund for that I just mentioned that
because in the past there has been
comment from members that maybe we're
allocating cell phones to communities
where no cell is likely to be generated
all the levels of SIL likely to be
generated at very very low so just to
point out to you that the contribution
to the one two three fund if you like
from those villages that are benefiting
has been quite considerable thank you
yes noted that and I've got a quick
question actually on these burger one
it's a clarification we we've been asked
to recommend the bid for fourteen
thousand three hundred and thirty three
pounds but in Appendix B when looking
through the technical assessment the
recommendation there is to improve the
bid for twenty one thousand three
hundred seventy seven thousand ninety
thank you I shall immediately refer that
to Christine therelike who's sitting at
the back thank you
yes this bid has we have been resolving
how much money that we would ultimately
pay towards this bid because of a
community grant and because the amount
of the estimates that were coming in
were only resolved at the last minute so
I would have to say that the monetary
figure in the technical assessment is
incorrect and the one in your
recommendation is correct thank thank
you it's Christine that the 14 that the
problem in the Chocula system it matches
both numbers the 14 33 3 in one of the
boxes in the table and then the number I
just quoted in in the bullet point
recommendation so just wondering affirm
if there is some specific reason for for
that I just think in this particular big
round we had two bits that were altering
very much at the last minute one was
Lebanon which almost didn't make it on
the list and one was the Easter Galt
proposal because of changes to estimates
and funds so I think the technical
assessment was written before we
actually settled on the final amount so
I would still direct you towards what we
have in the seal business plan and the
recommendation in your cabinet report
rather than the technical assessment
okay thank you very much Jesse thanks
that's I think that's clarified that and
counsel more easy Thank You mr. chairman
I'd like to ask council Aarthi and he's
informed us of those villages who have
actually contributed so can he tell us
what he's burgled has contributed in SIL
sorry can you not hear me I can if you
just give me a minute all I will do is
go onto the web pages and put in a salt
so if you just bear with me
it's a really good system you can tell
yourself and the amount all okay the
amount collected for this Bergdahl for
the sill one two three lists appears to
be just under thirty nine thousand
pounds thank you
it's actually more than I anticipated I
[Music]
think that's falling more than most of
us anticipated actually but but I take
the point yes hopefully that number will
increase quite considerably soon yep
does anyone else counsel Davis but I
just would like to to say for those that
are watching live stream and those
others the exocomp system is a brilliant
system and it is really easy to use to
find out all that information so just a
plug for ex-con there
thank you yes it is a very good system
and it's dead easy to interrogate and
get this kind of information it's just a
matter of seconds as counsel our fee is
just approved there right councillor
Busby well just to say that I don't
think I've should feel guilty about the
[ __ ] field infrastructure um every fund
are you planning on winning village of
the year again castle hub there are just
things it is a little disappointing that
we don't get a more varied application
from other parishes I think it is up to
us as members to ensure that we do pass
that message down to all our parish the
councils that the pot is there and
please you know investigate projects and
asked for help I think there's still
plenty of them that don't really
understand it and don't really have the
time to commit to putting a project
forward which I think comes down to us
to ensure that we give our time to them
and help them understand the sill
procedure yes that's very true we all
members need to do that and work with
their communities to take advantage of
this because the money is there and it's
there to be spent but for their benefit
councillor Davis yeah councillor Holt
was absolutely a hundred percent correct
and we as members all the members need
to do a bit more and to that end our
Community Grants review team are working
towards putting together a program for
better information for members to
understand how the grant system works
including SIL so hopefully when that
work those workshops come forward
they'll help the members have a better
understanding and be able to encourage
them and of course hopefully if Baber
were to adopt the locality awards that
will also help in the community
engagement and moving forward on that as
well thank you
right so we've got the the three items
that we've got to approve we've
discussed a bit about he's forgotten a
cot field does anyone have any comments
or anything they wish to say about
Lebanon it's a significant amount of
money that they need but we we know that
it's what it's there for and I
personally think it's a good use of cell
money labna ms a very proactive village
and I'm happy to to support that bit but
can I have any comments from anyone at
castle holt just one point of
clarification I
understand you said the site is a
complicated site due to its previous
history the money that we're putting is
it solely for the car park provision or
is it to make the site safe or is it to
clean the site there's an environment is
there anything that we're paying to help
the environmental cleanup of it or is it
just to provide the car parking it is
just to provide a car park but it is
slightly complicated by its former uses
of gas work so the provision of the car
park is a little bit more expensive than
it would be if it hadn't got that
history but the other elements of what
they're trying to do are not part of
this beard their to do with the
renovation of the gas holder a display
board so that's a visitor attraction in
its own right it's a scheduled ancient
monument those works are going to be
principally funded by a grant from
National Grid gas who have sold the site
to the Parish Council for a pound and
are also giving them a grant towards the
future future maintenance of the gas
holder so that's a that's a separate
project not part of this beard it's the
car park and the electric vehicle charge
of points in that car park that form
part of this bid Thank You Cathy
any other comments on on 11 bit it's a
an excellent project for the parish and
one that is very much needed
councilman BC how many electric charging
points are being installed to thank you
if I could just add to that though part
of the the sort of the idea behind what
they're trying to provide us to actually
get the power supply there so that the
number of charger points can be
increased at some time in the future as
you're probably aware the provision of
charge of points is restricted by the
supply so the idea is to get a supply
that's sufficient for more charger
points in the future should they be
required without actually putting in
lots of charge points that at the moment
may not be required this may be a flight
in fact sir but is it possible that at
some future date come probably not part
of this this Silby that they could
install battery storage there that can
be topped up during the night from from
the supply and then then used to augment
the supply for charging during daytime
no reason why they couldn't do that I
want to point out though that this is
Latin and parish councils bit not mine
so you're asking about all of the
details which I happen to know the
answer to yes I am - no but yes okay
everyone if there are no further further
questions or comments then we've got
these these three bits to approve and
the one to note councillor Aarthi has
proposed that it may have a seconder
Castle Busby all those a favor thank you
right moving on to the last item which
is paper BCA 1945 the joint area parking
management plan may ask column LBC to
introduce this please
Thank You mr. chairman
I bring to cabinet the joint area
parking management plan which cabinet
needs to approve in order for us to move
forward with civil parking enforcement
Suffolk County Council adopted a
high-level strategy in November 2018 and
we have to have regard to that strategy
and therefore produce our own which is
currently sitting as Appendix A the
joint area parking management plan is a
completely new policy document and it
sets out what we aim to achieve but it
also does not set out parking
restrictions in specific areas nor is it
a blueprint for paid parking we are
required to have a parking policy in
order to implement CPE which is due to
start on the 6th of April so I recommend
this joint area parking management plan
for approval thank you Thank You
councillor now I know that when this
came to our previous meeting we wanted
to defer it because there's a number of
questions that we had over CPA
implementation which no members wanted
clarification we have since had further
update on that in a briefing so which I
hope that has clarified concerns laid
some sufficient members about how CPS
going to be implemented and and where
there will be ready for the 6th of April
for for being able to and enforcing in
our district so in the light of that
we're now in a position now to to move
forward with with this plan does anyone
have any questions on what we have now
to us that's the hope yeah most people
know I'm not particularly happy with how
this has been done but I accept that we
do need to get this passed and I'm still
not content with the content of how of
the application of how the part is going
to be enforced and speaking to other
members I believe they haven't got a
clue either to be honest they they are
anticipating things that I don't think
are going to materialize and I think a
lot of people are going to be
disappointed and I have stressed since
we've had that briefing to all my
parishes whom won't have a lot of
regulation parking or yellow lines but
if they've got particular issues they
are to email me and we have agreed
previously that they can be forwarded to
the correct people who are then
hopefully offices to visit but I do
stress that the information that's come
through the members all members has been
very limited I believe in the fine
detail and I think it is the fine detail
of this that's the most important thing
our constituents and members of the
public and town councillors and parish
counselors are expecting a lot and I
hope I'm wrong but I don't think at the
moment this is in place to deliver what
they're expecting it may be that we
haven't managed their expectations and
if we haven't that is down to us I will
support this but as I say I do have
concerns about the actual content and
how it's going to be applied well
certainly in terms of the actual
enforcement itself we can only we can
only enforce where there are
restrictions in place double yellow line
so where there are no double yellow
lines there won't be any enforcement I'm
not aware of that but we do have
and we have been encouraged and
obviously you can get your residents via
you to to inform Suffolk County Council
highways of where there are particular
known problems so that we can ensure
that enforcement officers get get out to
those problems but I know councilman V
she wants to come back on that but there
is going to be a campaign of information
press releases etc in the run-up to a
policy so hopefully there'll be more
information that the people will be able
to have but cattlemen BC do you want to
to reply Thank You mr. chairman
CPE is very different to the joint area
parking plan and previa ting it yeah
essentially to engage in CPE which was
cascaded down by the Department of
Transport we are we have to follow
through from what the county has set as
an umbrella as an umbrella in their
high-level strategy document and as I
said in my initial presentation it does
not set out parking restrictions or
traffic regulations it it's not a
blueprint for seeing where we can raise
funds by charging for parking it's not
that it's just a policy document that
links in with the county councils
high-level strategy document which links
in to the Department of Transport
requirement to have these in place in
order to move to civil parking
enforcement business yeah
let's start by thanking councilor my
lazy because I know the amount of work
she's put into this with her team but
also the frustration she's suffered
different like dealing with the County
Councilman and others but our share
councillor Holt's concerns about this
because it does lack details we don't
know how many traffic enforcement
officers will be coming to Weber where
they'll be operating I think you know it
doesn't that details and I understand
you know we are part of a bigger picture
but I think from Baber residents you
know we need to understand more and
secondly if not one I've got the floor
it was announced this morning that the
government are looking to and parking on
pavements so how would that feed into
this particular policy or would that
come under a different policy very easy
Thank You mr. chairman and thank you
councillor the news that parking on
pavement may be banned will I believe
fall under the CPE there is I think it's
just a tightening up of the legislation
probably I'm sort of thinking here on my
feet because if the curb is dropped then
you can go onto the pavement
if there is a curb and it's not dropped
and you mount the pavement then you're
in soapy bubble water and I think the
government's are looking at just
clarifying and tightening up that area
because CPE will have probably caused
some issues it may be that now we're
launching it into a rural area these
issues are coming to the fore more more
pertinently
than they have done in the past but we
have been told advised by West Suffolk
by hips which
the equipment's bought the badges are on
the staff are employed they've been
trained but CPE is not what I am asking
you here today
CPE I will talk with the assistant
director and maybe we can do a
communication on CP e so that members
fully are up-to-date as up-to-date as we
are we must keep reinforcing the
distinction between this parking plan
and the implementation of CPE well
customer Osborne in Casper hold again
Thank You Sachin and yeah I also share
the concerns of my fellow councillors I
also understand that this isn't a
blueprint and a forcible parking
enforcement but I am concerned that I'm
contacted on a regular basis about when
civil parking enforcement does come into
place and that that various locations
will have the ability to apply for
residential parking permits now I can't
see that anywhere in this document my
concern is that when we go into the full
civil parking enforcement when it's
implemented and then we have little
requests or County have some requests
coming forward and say well it's not in
your parking plan it's not outlined in
there so I want to be reassured that we
will be able our residents will be able
to go through that process once civil
parking enforcement is implemented Thank
You councillor Osborne just a point on
parking permits it may entitle you to
park in the road but it doesn't entitle
you to park outside your house yes but I
will ask the assistant director to to
elaborate on the hand Thank You
counselor and so yes the the remit for
introducing those kind of permit schemes
resident parking permit schemes will be
with Suffolk County Council and what the
area parking plan does allude to is that
we will support communities where they
are looking for new traffic regulations
or permit parking scheme so almost we
were one of the stakeholders in that so
the County Council would look to us just
like their public to yourselves and
local community groups or the town or
parish councils to ask you about your
interpretation of whether that is how
you fit for purpose thing to do and so
that's where the district council would
play a part in any kind of and
applications for resident parking
schemes to Suffolk maybe you guys cuz
the whole yeah again I'm quite aware
that the young pumpkin benefit plan is
not CPE but obviously it does lead us
down the direction to deliver the CPE so
okay my concerns are noting um pavements
as far as I'm aware of certainly told by
Suffolk establish that you can park on a
pavements and once you don't block the
pavement so don't expect that you can't
park on a pavement it just is from from
my knowledge if you block so you could a
lady with a person with a buggy or
pushchair can't get through then that is
blocking a pavement you can park on a
pavement but not block it so I'm not
quite sure how that legislation will
come about was the Lord gave change
bring it in line with London that'll be
interesting to see because I think it'll
just lead to more chaos in our towns and
villages I don't think that's something
that we really would welcome to be
honest blocking pavements is one thing
parking on pavements I haven't a problem
with it
thank you so if I could just come in on
that and as councillor my VZ said the
Department of Transport have just
released a statement about this and for
me I really welcome that because it's
this really gray area between what the
police can still enforce and we'll still
enforce
whether they can actually get out of it
and then what CP covers so what is
happening is a consultation for a long
term solution around
parking will be coming out from central
government so as soon as that's
available I'll share that with
councilors so that we can all feed into
that together Thank You girls Rafi yeah
I think we've all got concerns about
this and we have had ever since we first
saw it but I think our concerns are more
operational and I don't think we ought
to be getting wrapped up in those at the
moment you know there will be
operational issues that will crop up
develop as we're doing this it's the
principal that's important and in terms
of the principal I think one of the
things we've got to consider is that
this has been the responsibility of the
County Council it will be our
responsibility
will that be better than it has been or
will it be worse and I believe it will
be much better so in terms of the
principal I think we should support this
thank you cuz I'm not sure it will be
our responsibility Klein I'm not sure it
will be our responsibility it might be
it's just Borough Council's and West
Suffolk so we might feed them the
information that we want but ultimately
we're not policing it we're guiding
someone else to do that for us and
that's the key to the problems I agree
that's for a later date but that isn't
necessarily our responsibility I don't
think it is um yeah my point was is it
going to be an improvement or not and I
think it will be an improvement that
remains to be seen I think we all we all
do expect an improvement after all we've
got pretty much a free-for-all at the
moment so anything is going to be an
improvement on on that Kozlov lvc Thank
You mr. chairman and and Thank You
councillor Aarthi for being supportive I
represent long Melford Ward and I'm sure
everybody has been through long Melford
and it's a lovely village and it has
pavements which are totally flush with
the road so you do not mount anything to
get onto the pavement you just drive
it's just there
and you get people parking with their
bumpers right up against the house or
the business so to hear that there's
some clarity coming through is great
news from the Department of Transport
but also I think the civil parking
enforcement is going to enable a light
to be shown on the bad Parkers in our
communities and hopefully through
penalizing them or counseling them to be
better citizens will actually improve
our environment and general well-being
because it is extremely frustrating in a
village that has a Main Street that is
three miles long with only one pelican
crossing or one pedestrian crossing when
people from the nursing home have to
walk a mile to it cross and then have to
walk a mile back to get whatever it is
they want and then they have to repeat
the exercise only to find that somebody
has gone on parked on the pelican
crossing itself so I personally to look
forward to CPE but I do ask the members
to support the joint area parking
management plan because that will lead
to the CPE thank you thank you guys for
a busy customer record do you have a
question this was really just a point I
think this is looking at the overview
part of the review and scrutiny and
maybe Cassandra can advise me on this
disco song isn't it yes is fine
when we when this came to scrutiny CPE
that is we looked at the toolkit which
was the range of measures the range of
approaches that could be taken for
actually applying CPE
now we weren't at the stage of applying
in CPE we were just looking at the
potential toolkit that would be
available to us the method of
that application has now been decided as
far as I can see that it will be a
mixture of West Suffolk and Ipswich
actually performing the enforcement now
as I see it and faking an overview here
the joint area parking management plan
is the basis on which we want to choose
the tools that we will employ so what
I'd like to ask is this and I think it
would answer the questions and concerns
of various cabinet members and members
in general and I'd go further the public
in general about the expectations and is
about meeting those expectations how are
we going to instruct West Suffolk and
Ipswich in what we want them to do what
specific measures we think should be
enforced according to this joint area
parking management plan because this is
just the plan so what the tools we're
going to ask them to do what what
measures what specifics and what degree
of expectation can the general public
expect to see now I have to say looking
at this and this is a point where mid
Suffolk and Weber have taken a different
view the mid Suffolk scrutiny committee
have taken the view that they want to
scrutinize this joint area parking
management plan and adrien as well and
myself did not feel that was necessary
simply because this is a policy document
there is nothing to scrutinize as such
this is the selection of the policies
point of which is scrutiny would be when
you've actually got something's happened
but CPE has been enforced say for a
period of the year and then you can go
back and you can scrutinize whether it
has been successful whether the
appropriate policies whether the
appropriate measures have been used and
do the policies and those measures need
to be changed that's a job for scrutiny
not before the event in this case so if
Sandra could give us some indication as
to how we move from a plan and the
toolkit into the measures and the
practical enforcement I think that
answers the questions you might correct
thank you I'm across a and if I thought
I'm sure people have heard me say this
and probably counsel amount amazing a
lot but it's just but just bear with me
so if I could just very briefly talk
about what is the District Council's
responsibility seeing what is Suffolk
County Council's responsibility and that
hopefully will fit into my own serve
around the policy application so the
District Council's responsibility is
known as off-street which is our own
Council owned car parks Suffolk County
Council's responsibility which is known
as on street is the highway traffic
regulation orders so in this instance
Baber and mid Suffolk have enforced
their own off street council car parks
for quite some time and they police have
been responsible for enforcing the
highway now what CPE does is passed
decriminalizes it from the police
responsibility over to a Suffolk County
Council civil responsibilities so what
the Suffolk County Council have done I
have to which most other County
Council's do across the UK is devolve
that responsibility to the district and
Borough Council's because they usually
have some kind of parking enforcement
teams already in place and it makes it
it's the same people that would do the
enforcement on the highway so for
efficiencies they put them as part of
the same team now a decision was taken
back in 2017 I believe to 4x which and
West Suffolk to undertake the
enforcement on our behalf for our
off-street Suffolk County Council
therefore followed that lead and agreed
for those to run to take the enforcement
for highways on street as well so where
where does that play into this these
parking policies I guess is that is the
end of that question
and so we do not have the fundamental
responsibility for parking policies on
the street however what we do have as a
stakeholder as a key stakeholder with
the council joining part of the Suffolk
parking partnership is how we can advise
or push agendas around parking policies
- Suffolk for the highway so Suffolk
Park in partnership is being instigated
as we speak so I think that we've met
you've met once so this is a partnership
that is politically as a political
strand and an officer strand so
strategies across both on-street and
off-street can be agreed they should be
supportive of what our parking plan
already says because we've aligned it
with the Suffolk parking permit parking
and plan and then an officer level we
will be led by the political strand to
make sure that those policies are
adhered to practically and practically
enforced out there on the highway I
don't know if that answers the question
somewhat so it there is that balance
between what we can what we have
responsibility for and what we can
influence captain McCoy won't come back
I could follow on from that then where
does feedings for specific proposals for
parking areas on Street where where does
that lie who has the responsibility and
what as the means of getting that
translated into action so in and it is
Suffolk County Council who has the
responsibility for any new traffic
regulation orders or and as counsel
Osborn mentioned earlier around parking
and permits so it would be for the
community normally a town or parish
council to look at where they feel that
there is an enforcement
Cerie that doesn't have a current
traffic regulation order that goes to
Suffolk County Council
now Suffolk County Council will then
instigate a consultation that would
include ward councillors portfolio
holders district councils and other
relevant community groups where they can
talk to you to see whether you feel you
would support that application and what
I will say because I know my count
accounts a colleague say it is that does
take a long time you know you're
normally looking around 18 months to
instigate a new traffic regulation order
and there is a cost to it that must be
found from somewhere and but so it is
Suffolk County Council
so to summarize and that please don't
think I am taking any pleasure in this
but the parish the community speak to
the highways in the county and then the
counties consult us and then we go to
hips which and West Suffolk to carry out
the enforcement it's a very sinuous
process isn't it it's not been any
different from all you don't need
replacing it switching from the police I
mean the other part of the procedures
just the same if I want to put double
yellow lines on the a12 between cook
talk and cable I raise a lot of money
but they don't go through cooked-up
Parish Council all I was saying is I've
got a feeling that CPA has raised
people's expectations to perhaps
ridiculous levels and it's just a good
point to make that perhaps it's not it's
not a universal panacea for of all
parking problems it's in part it seems
to me is to determine some simple as to
speeding you could get caught speeding
you could get caught parking badly it's
not a deterrent to all people
no but it's it's it's there to enforce
the regulations that are in place if you
need additional regulations then you
have to go through as cases explain the
process for getting those edition
regulations I noticed it we haven't
making a law or breaking something just
because somebody parks on the side of a
country lane they're not going to end up
getting a ticket but clearly where there
are double yellow lines then that that's
where the enforcement can take place and
it is up to us to make sure that the cpu
implementation officer is aware of
particular hotspots
obviously they they know about places
like the center of Sudbury the center of
Hadley but there are other places where
there are regulations in place which are
not necessarily on their radar and it's
up to us as the local members to to
bring it to their attention as I have
done regarding the the road coming out
of denim into Stratos Ameri where there
is now double yellow lines there in
place they were put down last year they
are ignored so that is an area that is a
hot spot that they are going to have to
focus on and and simply all of us need
need to identify similar hot spots in
our in our wards where there are
regulations in place which we know could
do with enforcement make sure that the
enforcement officers go there and and
and sort out the problems Hey Thank You
councillor movi C Thank You mr. chairman
and yes councillor McGraw is correct I
think everybody everybody's expectations
of CPE are unrealistic and it is and we
raised that with County that's our last
meeting and it is hoped and planned that
the PR message going out will help to
reduce that expectation level and direct
it to its realistic outcome the the
abbreviated term for the civil
enforcement officer is the C
oh so the CEOs will be will be visiting
all locations so hips which side will be
visiting all the villages etc into
Hadley and then West suffer coming up
through the villages and into Sudbury
and yes if you as a member have a
specific problem in a specific village
then please if it's West Suffolk side
please let me know and even if it's hips
which side please let me know and I will
disseminate it to the necessary people
because they need to they need to tour
around the villages in the area to get a
feel for what is where because they
won't live in Kersey and they won't live
in Lavenham they will they'll live
wherever in the county Thank You castle
ho I can't stop speaking about this and
I think John you earlier comment about
you've notified them of certain hot
spots I think that's a privileged as a
cabinet members that we've had because
we have the briefing on it but the
problem I have is that all the other
members haven't had that privilege and
it's the 12th of March and it comes live
the 6th of April and we're talking about
this now that's that's the problem I
have I just think the engagement with
members Town Council's and parishes has
been poor and their expectations are
very high and that's down to us but not
managing it and we haven't engaged
enough and allowed them to understand
how it's going to work I mean I was with
Hadley members yesterday afternoon and
Hadley Town Council and their
expectations are very high but they
haven't got a clue how it's good at the
administered that's Hadley Town Council
haven't got a clue and I think that that
just highlights the problems that we've
created for ourselves in
better but I will fully support this
thank you guys it is a matter of making
sure that our communications and
publicity on this over the next two
three weeks is is full and comprehensive
and gets out to everybody and I think
that's certainly something we we are
planning to work on isn't it yes yeah
cousin of easy Thank You mr. chairman
just to say this as the portfolio holder
and I've picked up the monkey I will run
with it and I will ensure that the PR
message now is going to be realistic and
will achieve correct expectation levels
okay great thank you
well we've had the recommendation
proposed by a California of the UC mayor
have a seconder please
councillor Busby all those a favor
thank you excellent right that concludes
today's meeting the next meeting
scheduled for the 9th of April 9:30 a.m.
thank you everybody